mit einer
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen waren wieder ich hab
mir nach wirklich sehr sehr langer zeit
sehr viele haben sich das natürlich
schon wieder gedauert
nein nicht schon wieder machen auf jeden
fall halten willst du wo man noch mal
und wir machen euch zusammen ein neues
video und zwar vier oscars überlegt er
das richtig krass 500 millionen daumen
nach oben wir uns 24 stunden im
management das war's auch schon wieder
mit dem video bis dahin
jeder von uns hat so richtig viel mehr
instagram will also nicht von uns trennt
sondern richtig so die krassesten answer
bilder die so am populärsten rausgesucht
und die zeigen wir jetzt halt so denn im
anderen der musste erraten
also die sind halt einfach so man kann
ihn nicht auf den er sich erkennen weil
einfach meine darüber ist oder sonst was
ihr wertersatz gleich sehen was ist ein
bekanntes instagram bild das weißt du
kannst dir ist ein bekanntes ist es
glaube ich ein foto wo wir beide im bild
sind aber da verfolgt uns allen drei auf
instagram einmal kurz eingeblendet danke
schön wenn wir durch ich gehe dann auch
bis nach wir fangen an mit dem ersten
bild und zwar hier wird mehr das ist
sein
nein alles verheilt früh prinzip ja
woran erkennt man sie sicher was sagst
du gehalten
ich glaube es also das wert ist die
kleinen sieht auf das sonderkonto einer
kleinen kanzlei named user kreativ
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nutzen wir diese pause für ein bisschen
werbung conar ein symptom wunderschöne
album und abonniert alles muss übrigens
der name alex wie meine idee war weil
ich damals gesagt war noch besser ist
wenn ich irgendwann nicht unbedingt jung
und zwar ist das wirtschaftlich werden
will
ihr werdet es auf jeden fall klappen die
zuschauer sollten auch kleine okay wer
ist das hier wie beauty playlisten du
sollst auch die berühmtesten der welt
nehmen natürlich nein dann irgendwer von
diesen jennas besser sei inzwischen das
ist nicht wenig den gibt's sonst macht
das ist nicht sagen ob und wie
vorsicht gemahnt wer kann er das hier
sein rücktritt mit einer katze welche
aussage hat ja gerade ich mache auch
einfach mal 2,3 millionen tut dann ist
es auf jeden fall das liebe vieh kamen
mit erkennen
nicht jedes installiert auswendig ich
habe es jetzt an der kamper sinnlos
alter richtig ist
[Applaus]
jetzt kommt noch was nicht leicht ist
wird leistet alles das ist was ein
kandidat fürs auf jeden fall sehr
schönen körper extrem politiker hoben
sie hat einen sehr betonten hinter
natürlich dass ich würde es war einfach
sagen dass keiner ist ich kann es doch
da kenne ich ja noch hier dran genau
angucken sich einfach dass es keine
heizung du sagst kenne ja alle gleich
ist alle blogger und es ist der prinz
muss statt zu sagen das ist alles nicht
so bekannt kennt diese person an patrick
blanc
was sagst du
sagst du sicher geht und man kann doch
ganz so lang man kann doch wer ist das
hier sein sohn die hand alles weil es
nämlich bitter war die jetzt sagen so
und alles junge bilder immer nur bilder
das ist langweilig ist habe jetzt hier
zwei master fragen will ein land das ist
halt doch frage nummer eins ja wer ist
der erfolgreichste instagram 2016 in
gänze in john hughes selena gomez wie
die aussage
ja denn rcd acht von den zehn
beliebtesten bilder 62 komponieren so
nächste bar
taylor swift ist doch die belegen soll
welcher ort ist der ort an dem die
weitere fotos gemacht werden
hollywood london hat sony war quadrate
ich dachte okay noch mal muss doch mal
kurz überlegen einzuholen muss ist mit
einem splitter ressourcen klopapier
board also jetzt welche stadt nicht
sagen der times square in new york
ich würde sagen der nordpol im madison
square garden in washington
würdest du willst ist in london
mindestens begann im sonderfall ist
beides falsch
die richtige antwort ist die spieler
danach kommt er jeweils videos danach
kommt der teils krasse park blut und was
ist mit dem mindestens belga der ist ob
das platzen wenn ihr noch mehr sehen
wollt schickt es auf jeden fall ganz so
für die wir beschreiben das video ab was
wir auf ihren channel gedreht wahrheit
oder pflicht bereitet es war so lustig
und so extreme sucht halt ich volle
wahrheit oder pflicht kann jeder wir
haben es gemacht
auf der straße lassen nach oben